she was on a basketball team with my
wife and then i had a podcast where we
would call play-by-play of the
basketball game but i don't there's a
documentary about it i'm the villain in
it oh you're not the i am too dude well
you're threatening can you do a little
bit of backstory so we can understand
this uh plot yes so aubry and my wife
amanda and other women were on this
women's league wreck basketball
team in l.a and it was just all these
kind of los angeles women's
writers performers and then other just
basketball players that would play
knights and then uh it was great and
then it became kind of a sensation and
there's a documentary about this team
that they were on called pistol shrimps
and then i think you jumped ship of that
team to to move to your good i traded at
the time i traded myself live on espn
this is a fact
which by the way nobody gave a [ __ ] but
kenny mayne you know kenny mayne he's my
friend i've known him for years i
convinced him let me go on espn because
it was right after the the decision the
lebron james yeah was it called the big
decision yes he made this very dramatic
decision i did my own decision no one
gave a [ __ ] i went on espn trading
myself to the spy squirrels
yeah
because
is this what you were vilified yes oh i
see it okay i traded myself to a
different team and here's why because i
wanted to play basketball as a hobby i
didn't want i i was trying to get away
from work and
bless the pistol shrimp's hearts i love
them all i had a great time on the team
but
i just wanted to do it to get my
you know my anger out my frustration i
like to play sports and then i would i
kept showing up to the thing and then
all of a sudden they'd be like all right
so we're doing practice and then we're
doing a photo shoot for the cover of the
la weekly and i'd be like a photo shoot
i'm trying to get away from the photo
shoot what are you talking about we're
just trying to play ball
because it's all actors you get a bunch
of actors and writers and everyone
together on a team then everyone starts
to make it and it was funny when you
guys started calling the games i was
fine but then strangers started showing
them to the game
they had signs with my name on it i'm
like i have an audience now yeah i'm
just trying to play this is getting you
away from your escape that's the problem
i was just trying to play ball bro just
trying to play you're talking to me i'm
an old time baller bro
hey brah i'm an old time baller so it
was funny though like i like how it
escalated but i was i i started having
panic attacks because i would show up to
the games and i would see a [ __ ]
audience like
i'm like these people are watching me
play basketball i got to like perform
for them no and then there was a whole
dance squad that grew up dancing and
that became all political and then the
reason i traded myself is because i want
to play with my sister
and there were rules on the on the
league like you couldn't once the roster
was set you couldn't just randomly play
on a random team and i wanted to play
with my sister so they wouldn't let me
so i then
played on an another team in disguise
i wore a wig
i'm sorry you cannot play basketball in
a disguise
no they've never heard of that i've
never heard of that before no they
didn't it was a donkey you know i know
i'm sure
but it's just so hilarious to me that
you would blew on a mustache and say i
am antonio the basketball player i wore
a blonde wig with goggles i gave them a
fake id
got on the court
literally first quarter
my acl tour on the court all eyes on me
and i was trying to
i was trying to you know be in disguise
i was like i don't want anyone like
is it possible that you got injured
because you were so committed to being
this other person it was karma it was
karma i don't know it was like oh you
don't want anyone to see you in disguise
like your knee is going to [ __ ] snap
right in half everyone's going to watch
you everyone's going to watch you get
carried out of here i love the idea of
someone switching to like a different
league or a different team and you know
playing in a disguise yeah i just think
that's fantastic yeah and i don't i
don't understand that you could really
try and pull that off i did
so what was that you said there was a
moment where aubry had to convince
someone to give her the ball what
happened was first of all i didn't
threaten anybody it was very civil we
were down like we were never winning the
game like we were done it was like the
last quarter and it was the point guard
of the other team and she was and i was
on her i was defending her and i just
she kept she knew who i was or something
and she was being a little sassy with me
she was like
she was kind of like yo like can i get a
picture with you after the game or what
like in the game she was like and i was
like yeah if you give me the ball right
now
because she was coming down the court on
her side and she was like i don't give a
[ __ ] and then gave me the ball and then
i just that's right and everyone because
nobody heard our conversation so they
didn't understand like what the [ __ ] did
you say to her for the point guard to
just be like all right here and i just
went back and did a layup and okay
matter we still lost there's another
idea i love which is someone who plays
on a basketball team who's
maybe either extremely uh famous in
another way not basketball or maybe just
independently very wealthy so they're
guarding someone and they it's just
understood that if you give my character
the ball he'll give you twenty five
thousand dollars in cash
and then it's just constantly yeah and
then at the end he's like okay you get
seventy five thousand dollars you get
six hundred fifty thousand dollars and
people like this is insane he scores
like 55 points a game
i love scams like this
that's not a good scare
that's a terrible scam